[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video i've got something a
little bit different for you guys
now it shouldn't come as a surprise to
anyone that in the vast world of harry
potter
there have been countless fanfictions
mortifs and alternate endings
written by the loyal fan base however
what you probably didn't expect to hear
is that one group of harry potter fans
who operate under the name
botnick studios utilized an algorithmic
tool
to rewrite a couple of pages of harry
potter content
the result probably unlike anything else
you've heard before
essentially what botnick studios did is
this
they leveraged predictive ai software
think
text messages and next word automated
predictions
however they train the software on the
harry potter books
rather than run-of-the-mill text
messages the result was one
three-page chapter of harry potter
entitled harry potter and the portrait
of what looked like a large pile of ash
now that's a title if you ask me the end
result
well probably what you'd expect
something that
vaguely resembles harry potter with a
whole lot of absurdity
i want to make it clear that the piece
itself was not entirely generated by ai
in fact it was written by many
potterheads who collaborated on the
effort
taking advantage of the predictive
algorithmic tool
i'm not going to read the whole thing
for that you can follow a link in the
description
to the botnick studios website but i am
going to give you a sample
page 271 chapter 13
the handsome one the castle grounds
snarled
with a wave of magically magnified wind
the sky outside was a great black
ceiling
which was full of blood the only sounds
drifting from hagrid's hut
were the disdainful shrieks of his own
furniture magic
it was something that harry potter
thought was very good
leathery sheets of rain lashed at
harry's ghost as he walked across the
grounds towards the castle
ron was standing there and doing a kind
of frenzied tap dance
he saw harry and immediately began to
eat hermione's family
ron's ron shirt was just as bad as ron
himself
if you two can't clump happily i'm going
to get aggressive
confess to the reasonable hermione page
what about ron magic offered ron to
harry
ron's a loud slow and soft bird harry
did not like to think about birds
death eaters are on top of the castle
ron bleated quivering
ron was going to be spiders he just was
he wasn't proud of that
but it was going to be hard to not have
spiders all over his body
after all is said and done look said
hermione
obviously there are loads of death
eaters in the castle
let's listen in on their meetings the
three complete friends
zapped onto landing answered the door to
the castle roof
they almost legged it but witches are
not climbing
ron looked at the doorknob and then
looked at hermione with searing pain
i think it's closed he noticed locked
said mr staircase
the shabby robed ghost they looked at
the door screaming about how close it
was
and asking it to be replaced with a
small orb the password was
beef women hermione cried that should be
enough to give you a rough idea of the
absurdity of this predictive text
masterpiece
but i implore you all to follow the link
in the description where you can check
out the rest of botnick studio's
work and that's it for this video if you
enjoyed the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel
until next time beef women
you